[Music]
everybody knows young people are
watching less television these days okay
they just are a oh yeah it's true they
get they get most of their entertainment
from the internet that's just the way to
experience everything so I thought I
should try to relate to some of my teen
and tween viewers by presenting this
show occasionally in a format that feels
more familiar to them I think it's just
intelligent so once again please enjoy
my latest Conan videoblog a Conan
O'Brien here this is my video blog this
is my room this is my room and here's
what's happening in my world I saw that
movie lawless starring Bane from Batman
and Shia LaBeouf and Shia LaBeouf has
like the best name but my computer has a
really hard time pronouncing it watch
this I'm gonna type Shia LaBeouf
okay now I'll convert it into speech see
you later you know let's see how it
pronounces Mahmud Ahmadinejad Mahmoud
Ahmadinejad
okay here's here's a really hard one
mamasay mamasa mamakusa alright I
invented it I invented a new snack
here's what I did I licked a bunch of
Jolly Ranchers and I stuck them on to an
oven mitt and it's really awesome that
then call it a flavor mitt you can just
lick it any time you want then about an
hour a cat fell asleep on it but this
side though really good and this side
you know this last segments called
animals with Paul Ryan's eyes and
animals with Paul Ryan's eyes okay
here's Paul Ryan alright here's some
animals with his eyes okay
here's a seal
here's a lemur here's an owl and here's
a frog
that was animals with Paul Ryan's eyes
animals with Paul Ryan's eyes